MODERATOR: Thank
you all for coming
to another Talks at Google
event this afternoon.
Today, were extremely thrilled
to hose Professor Bob McChesney
and John Nichols.
They're presenting a
talk today, a discussion,
about their latest book,
which is called "Dollarocracy:
How Money and the Media Election
complex is Destroying America."
And I think, especially given
the events of recent news
and also the state of
the continual campaign
that's in American politics
today, the idea of media
literacy is very important and
the balance between free speech
and campaign contributions
and what role
the media plays in all of this.
And so we're really thrilled to
bring this dialogue to Google
today.
Professor McChesney is from
my alma mater, the University
of Illinois, where he teaches
in the communication department.
And he's also the president and
co-founder of the "Free Press."
John is a journalist
and blogger and also
the associate editor of "The
Capital Times" up in Madison.
So we have the Midwest
representation here.
And so we will have some time
at the end for questions.
We'll use this mic.
So hunt me down if you
have a question at the end.
Otherwise, please join me
in welcoming Bob and John
to Google.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY: Well,
thank you all for coming out.
It's an honor to be
at Talks at Google.
We've been in a tour
all over the country.
This is our 35th or 40th talk.
And we've got about
20 more to go.
And the response to the book has
been extraordinarily positive.
And as you'll see,
it's also surprising
because it's a very
depressing picture
we're about to paint
on what's going on
with our political system
and the corruption in it.
But the reason why the response
has been positive, I think,
on one hand is that
people recognize
the truth of what we're saying,
that the evidence points fairly
strongly in this direction.
But the other reason is
that John and I both think
we're in the moment of change.
That really this system
can't go on for much longer
and that the great crisis we
face in the United States today
is that our political system
is over here, very much
bounded by moneyed interests.
But the great bulk of the
population isn't with that.
They're over here.
They want real solutions
to real problems
that our country faces.
And they know that our
government needs to provide.
And this tension is growing
greater and greater by the day.
And it's that
tension that's going
to create the birth, we
think, or the rejuvenation
of a movement to really
re-democratize this country
or democratize it much
more than it is at present.
When we talk about
dollarocracy, what we refer to
is fairly self-evident.
Democracy means the rule of
the people, the rule of money.
Going from the
Greeks, dollarocracy
means the rule of money,
not the rule of people.
$1, one vote rather than
one person, one vote.
Those with a great deal of
money have tremendous influence
over politics.
Those with no money
have no influence
over politics whatsoever.
Two recent studies published
by Princeton University Press
really encapsulated
this problem,
one by Marty Gilens, another
by a team of scholars.
They reached independently
the exact same conclusion,
which is if you look at the
Congress of the United States
today, none of the
decisions that are made
reflect the interests
of the great majority
of the voters of this country,
the values of their voters.
Representatives routinely ignore
what their own constituents
want when they deal
with their decisions.
The decisions are
made almost entirely
on behalf of the most
wealthy and powerful,
self-interested
parties to the policy
or the law or the budget item.
A month ago, we were
in Washington, DC.
And we had a book launch party.
And the person who wrote
the foreword to our book
graciously introduced us,
US Senator Bernie Sanders.
Bernie has been in the US
Senate now seven years.
Before that, he
served eight terms
in the US House of
Representatives.
And he said, unequivocally,
unconditionally,
that it is impossible
for anything
to pass the US Congress
if it is opposed
by either corporate America
or Wall Street-- impossible.
They basically have veto
power over all legislation.
And that, in a nutshell,
is dollarocracy.
That's not democracy.
Just this last summer, Jimmy
Carter, the former president,
was meeting with a number
of dignitaries from Germany,
talking about American
and global politics.
It was supposed to be an
off-the-record meeting.
Thanks to the
presence of an iPhone,
it became an
on-the-record meeting.
And Carter said,
the United States
is "no longer a
functional democracy."
No longer a
functional democracy.
We are off the Democratic grid.
We no longer have
the rule of law.
We no longer have the
accountability one associates
at the base level with a
self-governing or democratic
society.
And then to top it
off, in the book,
we go through a lot of the
polling data and survey
data that shows that most
Americans are familiar with it.
This is not something
that shocks Americans.
They get it.
They understand
the powerlessness
they have politically
that's frustrating to them.
One survey that's most
striking was that almost half
of Americans think we would have
a better Congress if we simply
drew names out of a hat rather
than went through the election
process.
That's a laugh line.
But then people think
about it and say,
you know, maybe that's
not such a bad idea.
For those of you who know your
history of democratic theory,
that's how the ancient Greeks
made most their decisions.
It came through the jury
system, not through elections.
So at any rate, dollarocracy
is the term we have for this.
And it has immense consequences.
The most obvious ones, the
ones we're all familiar with,
is corruption.
That the decisions that are
made in budgets and policies
and laws are dominated by
self-interested, large,
profitable commercial interests.
But it also has a lot
of other consequences.
And they are the
consequences that
really shape the
life of this country
going forward until
they're addressed,
until something is done
about dollarocracy.
We have seen a massive increase
of an inequality in the United
States in the last 35 years.
And this is what you would
expect in a dollarocracy.
Those at the top rig the
system so the funds go to them.
The benefits go to them.
And the resources don't
flow towards the bottom.
We've seen an enormous increase
in poverty in the last 35 years
in the United States.
Virtually all the
gains we made, which
were enormous from the 1920s
to the 1960s to reduce poverty,
have been lost.
We're back at poverty rates and
low income rates in the United
States today equivalent to
where we were 80 years ago.
We've lost almost all our
gains in the past generation.
Economic stagnation.
The certified range of
debate over economic policy
by the dollarcrats
in Washington, DC,
is entirely comfortable with
high rates of unemployment
and lower real wages
for most workers.
That's just not even debated
by either party, by anyone,
in Washington.
It's just a narrow
range of debate.
That's not much of a future.
Basically, what we have now,
based on current policies,
is what we're
getting going forward
for the great bulk
of American people.
And then there's another point
here that's too often lost.
One of the great things about
America, one of the things
I think all Americans
treasure most,
is our civil liberties-- freedom
of speech, freedom of religion,
freedom of the press, right
to assemble peacefully.
Well, when you lose democracy,
when it becomes a dollarocracy,
your liberties, those
rights we cherish the most,
are on softer ground.
You still have the right
to tattoo something
on your forehead or to have
a haircut of your choosing.
But when you start
challenging people
in power, what rights really
are all about, the ability
to stand up to those in power,
you're on softer ground.
And we've seen, for example,
just this last week, a week
and a half ago, for the
first time in its history,
the Committee to Protect
Journalists, an organization
which defends freedom of the
press and journalists' rights
worldwide against autocratic
governments for the first time
issued a report on
harassment of journalists
by the US government--
first time in its history.
And I'd submit that's what
you get in dollarocracy.
Under dollarocracy,
those rights,
those freedoms that we once
took for granted to the extent
they mix with people in power,
suddenly are less secure.
Well, the solution, in our
view, to dollarocracy is clear.
It's democracy.
And in this book,
what we argue is
that the election system, which
is the main way citizens have
a way to exercise democracy,
has been greatly corrupted.
And that's really
where the problem is.
And our book looks at
how it's been corrupted.
So the ability of the
vote and the voter
has been reduced tremendously.
And money has come to
rule it a great deal.
Now, our book is
fairly depressing.
You can always get
the vibe right now
where I'm going with it,
where we're going in the book.
But American history is
not a constant series
of depressing outcomes,
quite the contrary.
Between 1900 and 1970,
democratic forces,
popular forces in
the United States,
won a number of enormous
victories, huge victories.
We won the right to
have trade unions.
We won social security.
We won Medicare.
We established public education
for working class people
vastly superior to almost
anywhere in the world.
We extended higher education
to a higher percentage
of the population than
anywhere else in the world.
We reduced poverty dramatically.
And by the 1960s, we had
less economic inequality
than we'd ever had since
the Industrial Revolution.
We were really,
in many respects,
moving forward rapidly.
Now, it was up and down.
There were fights.
There were contests.
It wasn't all wins.
But it wasn't all
defeats either.
By the end of the 1960s,
and I was a teenager then,
they did a survey in 1970 of
all the teenagers in the world.
And they found out
that American teenagers
were among the three most
optimistic groups of teenagers
in the world.
The other two were
Israeli and Chilean.
Chile fell off the
list a few years later.
And America fell
off the list too.
We're way down the
list now when they
do those surveys
in 40, 50, 60, 70.
We're nowhere near the top.
And I was a teenager then.
And I remember the
optimism we had.
We thought this country had the
capacity to solve its problems.
We made all this progress.
And we were within eyesight
of a much better world
with even less inequality, less
poverty, more opportunity, more
justice, less
militarism, and less war.
But not everyone was
optimistic in the early 1970s.
In particular,
the leading lights
in the business community
were deeply concerned by what
they saw going on in
America at that time.
They were concerned
that America was not
sufficiently reverential
towards traditional business
domination of politics.
They were deeply concerned that
the most honored and respected
person in American life in 1970
across the political spectrum
was Ralph Nader.
Ralph Nader, who's vision
was that public service was
the highest calling a person
could do to serve others
and that people
could work together
and democratically have the
government solve problems
effectively on behalf
of all the people.
The government
did not have to be
a source of
corruption or tyranny.
That was Nader's message.
And this scared the
business community
to death, which saw its
stature in the country
probably at its lowest ebb in
generations by the early 1970s,
especially, interesting
enough, among middle class
and upper middle class students.
College students,
who traditionally
were the backbone
of business society,
suddenly had a marked
increase in concern
that large corporations
weren't the best
way to structure an
economy for a free society.
In the early 1970s, the
US Chamber of Commerce
commissioned a confidential
memo to be distributed
among five or six dozen
leading CEOs and investors
to deal with what they
termed the political crisis
of our time.
And they termed it the
crisis of democracy.
And the crisis of
democracy to them
was that there was
too much democracy.
The crisis of democracy
was that women,
African Americans, young
people, young workers, who
traditionally had been
apathetic and not concerned
with politics, had gotten
too engaged in politics,
were making demands on the
system the system really
couldn't accommodate.
We had to get them back on the
couches, back in apathetic,
back and unconcerned
with politics.
And the US Chamber of
Commerce commissioned
the leading corporate
attorney in America
at that time to write a memo.
And this attorney's
name was Lewis Powell,
who made a vast fortune
representing firms, especially
in the US tobacco industry.
And the Powell memo, you can
Google it after the talk.
It's up there.
It's six pages long.
It was done in 1971.
It was a blueprint, basically,
for how corporations
can take over the
government of the country
with the goal of
making it very simple.
No matter who wins
the election, we win.
Business domination
of society is never
in question
whichever party wins.
That was the mission of it.
And what Powell argued
was that business
needed to devote immense
resources to lobbying
and politics.
And in the two decades
following the memo,
there's was a tenfold increase,
10 times increase in lobbying
and political spending
by corporations.
10 times increase in the number
of lobbyists in Washington, DC.
The term K Street, which
didn't exist before 1971,
became a term like Wall
Street or Madison Avenue
to signify an enormous industry.
Washington, DC, which had
been a sleepy backwater
town without much
wealth, compared
to the Clevelands, or
the Bay Areas, or the New
Yorks, or the Philadelphias
of the world, suddenly,
after the influx of corporate
money and the lobbying,
became a very
different community.
Today, four or five of the 10
richest counties in the United
States are the suburbs
ringing Washington, DC.
And those aren't government
bureaucrats living there.
They're the people of K Street.
They're the corporate
people living there and all
their ancillary people.
So they've succeeded.
Now, one thing that Powell
was insistent on in his memo
was they needed to
build groups that
would buttress the ideological
and political power
of corporations-- Heritage
Foundation, CATO, American
Enterprise Institute came
immediately following this.
ALEC, a group that you've
been learning more about here
at Google apparently, came
immediately after this.
And then, most
importantly, we've
got to do something
about the Supreme Court.
Even when we have
Republican presidents who
are pro-business, like
Eisenhower and Nixon,
they're appointing these guys
like Earl Warren and Harry
Blackmun.
And they get a
lifetime appointment.
And they get carried away
with the First Amendment
and the idea of
expanding democracy.
We've got to get guys in
the court, when we put them
on the court, we
know they will always
understand business
first, business always.
Business has to dominate.
So they set up something
called The Federalist Society
to be a training ground
for their attorneys,
so they could count on them
when they got in the court.
And as fate would have it,
two months after this Powell
memo was distributed
confidentially and gendered
a great deal of discussion
internally in the business
community, there's an opening
on the US Supreme Court.
And who should President
Nixon decide to appoint?
Lewis Powell.
He became the next judge
in the Supreme Court.
So he had a chance to
swing right into action
and implement his ideas as a
member of the US Supreme Court.
And Powell's signature
issue from the moment
he came to the
court was the idea
there should be unlimited
spending by corporations
and wealthy people on politics.
That was his immediate issue.
He was obsessed with that.
He was never able to win that
fight on the Supreme Court
while he was on it,
because the Chief Justice
at the time, William
Rehnquist, was
an old-fashioned conservative.
He didn't believe
corporations were people.
He didn't believe the
Supreme Court should
mess with the structure of
elections to play favorites.
He opposed the efforts
to have unleashed money.
But by the time John
Roberts replaced
Rehnquist in 2010,
all that changed.
John Roberts was a
Federalist Society superstar.
He was committed to
unlimited spending
by business and billionaires
and trade unions.
And for those of
the younger people
here, ask some of the old
people what trade unions are.
They're these things we used to
have back in the '60s and '70s
that gave workers some higher
income than they have today.
And the Citizens United
decision came on in 2010.
And that's really what
drove this book, because
with Citizens United, what we
saw was businesses, unions,
and billionaires can
spend unlimited amounts
on political campaigns, as
long as the money didn't
go officially to
the campaign itself.
It went to a third-party
group that was not
associated with the
campaign but could
be linked to it informally,
as we learned in 2012.
And as a result, we saw in
the last election, 2012,
in the United States,
we spent $10.3 billion
on all our elections,
double what
was spent in 2008
and all the elections
in America, 10 times what
was spent 20 years ago,
even factoring inflation.
We're way huge
increase in spending.
Now, the Supreme Court argued
this huge increase in spending
would be a good thing,
because there would just
be more civic virtue.
More money is more speech,
more involvement by people.
But there's a fundamental
problem with that argument.
There's a big difference
between anyone
in this room giving
$50, $100, $200, even
$1,000 to a candidate
and someone giving
100 times or 1,000 times that.
It goes from being
a civic contribution
to being an investment with an
expected outcome commercially.
All the evidence has
always pointed that way.
All the evidence continues
to point that way.
Now, it's difficult to fully
get the evidence on that
in the short term,
because most of the people
are dropping lots of money.
And much of this money
is now anonymous.
As we chronicled
in the book, there
are no records that are kept.
Don't want to be publicized.
If you drop $50 or $100
million on a referendum case
on labeling of
foods in California,
for example, you
don't really want
to necessarily
advertise who you are.
You want to keep it on the
down low as much as possible.
You just want to win.
But fortunately for us
in doing our research,
there was one major donor
who gave $200 million
in the last election cycle
who enjoyed the publicity
and reveled in it.
He's from Las Vegas, Nevada.
His name is Shelly Adelson.
You might have heard of him.
Shelly dropped $200
million, as I said.
And after the election, everyone
said, well, poor Shelly.
He lost $200 million.
He had a rough year.
All his candidates lost.
Well, not all of them.
In Michigan, there
was a referendum
on the ballot to make the right
to have collective bargaining
part of the Michigan
constitution
so the government couldn't take
away that right from workers.
It looked like it
was going to win.
Michigan, after
all, is the backbone
of the labor movement
in the United States.
In the last few weeks,
Shelly took an interest
in that state in that race and
dropped a few million dollars
quickly to run
negative ads against it
and was able to defeat
it at the last second.
So he won some things.
He didn't lose everything.
Shelly Adelson had a very
interesting interview
after the 2012 election.
He went to Washington
so all the Republicans
could kiss his ring.
And "The Washington
Post" interviewed him.
And the reporter said, what are
your politics, Shelly Adelson?
What motivates you?
He said, well, these
are my political values.
I believe in
socialized medicine.
I believe in stem cell research.
I'm concerned about
the climate crisis.
I think we probably have
to do something about that.
I believe in science.
I believe in a woman's
right to choose.
I believe in gay rights
and gay marriage.
The reporter is dumbfounded.
Are you the same Shelly Adelson
who just gave $200 million
to Rick Santorum and
all these lunatics?
And I'm paraphrasing here.
And he said, yeah.
He said, I don't give money
to politics for those reasons.
When I give money to politics,
I've got three basic concerns.
Number one, I hate labor unions.
I have a nonunion shop.
I'm a billionaire.
I don't want to have
the unions in my shop.
So I'm for politicians
who are going
to make sure we don't have
to worry about labor unions.
Number two, I'm
worth $30 billion.
I don't like paying taxes.
That's for the little people.
I want politicians
to keep my taxes low.
And for what I spend, I get
a 1% drop in my tax rate.
It more than pays for whatever
I give any politician.
And number three, I
run gambling casinos.
You might know that that's
sort of a dubious enterprise
to a lot of people.
And some of the stuff I'm doing
in my East Asia casinos people
are looking at as
maybe being a little
in the gray area of legality.
I prefer to have a
government that's
not going to look
very hard at that.
That's why I give $200 million.
I'm worth $30 billion.
I want to be worth $60 billion.
I don't want to be worth
$10 billion or in jail.
And so he laid it out.
It's all about investment.
And when the Citizens United
decision unleashed the money
from the Shelly
Adelson's of the world,
it had no effect on
the 99.99% of Americans
who were in no position to give
more than $100,000 or $200,000
a year in elections.
It was all about Shelly Adelson
and a few thousand other people
who can drop $200 million.
It was their liberation
pact was for them
to be able to buy elections.
That's what that decision did.
It had no effect on
99.9% of Americans, zero.
But for Shelly, it was great.
Now, let's think
about that money.
So we outspend most countries
by a great deal of money.
Germany, as you
might know, recently
had a national election.
Just a month ago, they reelected
their Christian democratic
government.
And John Nichols
and I went through.
And we did the math.
We figured out how
much did Germany
spend on their campaigns.
All their politicians, all
their candidates per voter,
how much did they spend on
the German national election
this year?
And how did that compare to
how much American politicians,
parties, and third-party groups
spent on our election in 2012?
For every dollar they
spent in Germany this year,
for every dollar on campaigns
for their national elections,
we spent $32 on our
national elections,
congressional and presidential
in 2012-- 32 to 1 ratio.
And from our research,
basically, that's
pretty much the ratio
everywhere around the world.
It's sometimes down
to 8 or 9 or 10 to 1.
But the larger the country
is, the more it gets up.
Britain was 29 to 1
for the 2010 election
compared to us in 2012.
We spend unbelievable
amounts of money
compared to these
other countries.
Now, according to
Citizens United,
that should give us the
best elections in the world.
We're outspending them.
All that speech.
All that public involvement.
Well, let's think about that.
Imagine we outspent
Germany 32 to 1
in elementary school
education in America.
What would it be like?
Take what Germany spends to
educate a first grader and say,
we outspent them by 32 times.
What would an American
elementary school
look like in Oakland today?
You'd have one teacher.
You'd have four students.
You'd have four
assistant teachers.
You'd have a music teacher,
an art teacher, a gym teacher,
a personal trainer, a masseuse.
You'd have this unbelievable
network of people
to educate our kids.
Every kid in America
would get an education
equal to Bill Gates'
kid, if not better.
32 to 1 spending
advantage over Germany.
It would be unbelievable.
So what happens when you
outspend a country 32 to 1
on elections?
Unbelievable?
Yeah, unbelievable but
in the other direction.
We have the worst
elections in the world.
Jimmy Carter has said,
again-- and the Carter Center
monitors elections.
They've monitored 92
elections in the last 25 years
to make sure they're
on the up and up.
Jimmy Carter said
that the United States
has arguably the worst
election system in the world.
He said that if the
Carter Center was
asked to monitor an
American election,
they would refuse to do
so, because we don't meet
the baseline credibility
level you have to have
that Venezuela meets,
that Ukraine meets,
the Belarus meets.
We don't meet that
baseline criteria
that they would hold a
country to that they could
trust the outcome
of the election.
That's what Carter said.
Our elections are deplorable
by international standards.
We get the lowest
turnout rate in the world
among major countries.
Germany had a 72% turnout.
Norway, three weeks before
their national election, 82%.
We had just under 53% of
18-year-olds and older vote
in our 2012 election.
People were ecstatic.
53%.
Unbelievable.
We're very low.
And where does the money go?
And this is really why
so much has been spent.
The money goes
overwhelmingly to television
political advertising.
And this is much of
what our book is about,
because it's become the lingua
franca of American politics.
In 1776, the book that
drove most Americans
to be willing to fight to
make this country independent
was a pamphlet by Tom Paine
called "Common Sense."
And it was the most widely
read book of its period,
perhaps even more
so than the Bible.
And in the first sentence
of that book, it says,
a long habit of not
thinking something
wrong gives it the superficial
appearance of being right.
And that's how most of us
are about American politics.
We're so inundated in the
idea of political advertising
as the lingua franca, we think
that's what democracy is.
That's what we think
democratic elections are.
Wrong.
It's not like that at all.
Not like that at all.
Political advertising
is outlawed
in all the countries
I just named.
You can't do it in Germany.
You can't do it in Norway.
They don't allow it to be spent.
That's where we spent $6 of
our $10 billion last time
on these political
ads, which are
of extraordinarily
dubious value.
In other countries,
like Britain, they're
considered to political
campaigns what germ warfare is
considered to
conventional warfare.
They're considered simply
outside the boundaries
of a healthy democracy
and unacceptable.
But in this country,
that's what we have.
And in this country,
increasingly what we have
are negative ads.
Ads that, basically,
are all about attacking
the opponent in a
scurrilous manner
with a factual basis that is
laughable at the most part.
I could go on and on.
I think you get the hint
of where we're going.
The good news though, we are
on a chance of changing it.
The bad news though is that the
one institution that normally
would be at the front of leading
us would be our news media,
our political journalism,
which would draw people in,
make them aware.
And the crisis we
talk about in the book
is not only of our
election system,
but it's of the
collapse of journalism
as we know it in the United
States in the last 20 years.
The resources going to
journalism have plummeted.
In most communities we go
to, there are maybe 30%,
35% the number of paid
reporters there were,
including digital,
from 1990 or 1992.
In some communities,
it's much less.
There's just not
much journalism left.
The commercial
community has decided
you can't make money doing it.
They're not doing it.
Most people who go to vote
now, they have no information
whatsoever about most of
the races on the ballot.
What little journalism you
get for the races at the top
is usually just regurgitating
the claims in the TV ads
and discussing them
and how effective
they are, very little about the
actual candidates or policies.
So very much the
crisis of dollarocracy
is the crisis of the loss
and collapse of journalism.
And the solution to
the crisis is not only
changing our election laws,
changing our Constitution
to guarantee the right to
vote, but also creating
a healthy, vibrant,
independent news media.
And on that note,
I'd like to introduce
my co-author, John Nichols.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN NICHOLS: Bob McChesney.
Can everybody hear this well?
Bob's a little
taller than I. And I
thought the microphone was
not particularly well set up
for him.
And I'm hoping I will project
well enough so everybody
can hear you, because
we've come to Google to ask
you to work, not
merely to listen.
And a huge part of
our research-- and I
know this guy sitting
up front is saying, hey,
I work all the rest of the day.
I don't want to be
told to do more here.
Look, you're a unique
bunch of people.
Do you understand?
It's not every
corporation in America
where midday when you have
a lunch break you come out
and sit in the middle of the
operation and listen to people
pontificate about the
politics and the functioning
of democracy.
So right off the bat, you
have self-selected yourself
into a unique grouping.
You also created
the technology that
makes it possible
for Eric over there
to look up the Powell
memo and actually read it
as Bob talked about it.
And that's a huge part of where
we are at as a democracy today.
People rely on what you
do to get information.
Now, that's a little bit tragic.
That's not a perfect scenario,
because you understand
that in a functioning
democracy, information on
ought to come from all sorts
of different directions.
And people shouldn't have
to work particularly hard
to find out about
what's going on,
because despite the fact
that Eric looked up the memo
and got all his information,
by and large, most people still
get their information about
democracy from local television
news.
Now, I'm not going to ask you
to watch your local television
news.
That would be an unreasonable
request of any functioning
human.
But just for an experiment
tonight, if you get a chance,
pop it on and look at
what most Americans get
as the input of information
as regard to democracy.
They're not even getting
sufficient information
to get them to know what
to Google to find out
more about their democracy.
When they watch
their local evening
news, what they get in
most of this country
is weather, a lot of weather.
In fact, the fact
of the matter is
I don't even
understand how you can
have weather reports
in California.
But I have watched it here.
No, I come from Wisconsin.
We have weather.
It's going to snow tonight.
But if you watch the
local evening news,
it begins with-- I don't
care what's going on.
The government is shut
down, debt ceiling crisis,
death, grief, hate,
sorrow, whatever.
They'll tell you something big.
And then they'll
say, but first, we're
going to let you know
about the weather.
And they will go to a very
handsome or attractive person
who will sit there
and say, well,
today we had a lot of weather.
And I'll be back to tell you
more about it after the break.
And then they go, and they give
a huge amount of commercials.
And then they do the
smash and grab news
of the day-- death, death,
grief, sorrow, robbery,
car crash, traffic jam, death,
death, grief, sorrow, robbery,
car crash, traffic jam.
Most newscasts have about
27 stories mentioned.
When we ask people, they
often say, oh, a newscaster
will probably do
three or four stories.
No.
They do about 27 hits.
But it's all just reading
one line after another.
And it's invariably
something horrible
going on someplace that makes
you really dislike and distrust
your neighbors.
And so once they've got done
with that though jamming that
in, not enough time to cover
the school board or the city
council or the state
legislature, mind you.
Then they get back
to the weather.
And that's where they let loose.
That's where you're going to
get your detailed and useful
information.
They're going to tell
you that in Mountain View
it was 73 degrees today.
But up in South San
Francisco, it was 70.
And over in Palo Alto, it was
71, if you can believe it.
And then they're going to
go all through the region.
You know this,
because one time you
watched the locally
evening news.
And so they go all around
with all that stuff.
And then they give you
the barometric pressure,
which I've covered journalism.
I've been a journalist
for 30 years.
I've watched the evening
news in every place,
not just in this country.
I've been in 25 countries
around the world.
I have no idea what
barometric pressure is.
But I understand it's important.
And they tell you all
about it every night.
And then what do they do?
This is the important part.
In the seven to
eight minutes devoted
to weather, they go, well,
over here across the Pacific,
around Thailand, there seems
to be a storm stirring up.
And if the wind
blows the right way,
it might come up across the
Pacific and, I don't want,
in a couple weeks, we
might have some rain,
because they did this.
They look across the whole.
They tell you a weather
patterns as stuff.
And you're like, wow, this must
be the most important stuff
in my life.
This must be what
really matters.
As a citizen, I have to know
this in order to function.
And then they throw in a
bunch more commercials.
And then after the
bunch of commercials,
because you're there
with baited breath
to know what the weather
will be tomorrow,
they go around the
whole map again.
And they say, in
Palo Alto tomorrow,
it's very likely to be 73 and
up in South San Francisco, 71.
But take a look at this.
Mountain View is looking like
it might get to 75 tomorrow.
We're not sure.
But we'll be keeping
an eye on that.
And so they've done seven, eight
minutes of this, seven, eight
minutes of the central place
where the average American gets
their information about politics
and governance on the weather.
There's only one problem.
The weather is free.
The weather doesn't
require any journalism.
The weather is created
by the government.
I know.
You're like, hold it.
They invited another
nut into Google.
No.
The weather comes from the
National Weather Service.
You, the taxpayers,
pay for the collection
of all that information.
And the TV stations
get it for free.
They don't pay for it.
And so they give you seven or
eight minutes of no journalism.
They don't even go out
and check the thermometer.
And then at the end
of that newscast,
they say, well, you know
everything you need to know.
Go out there and decide who
should be the President, who
should be your
senator, how we should
run our local governments,
how you should feel
about major issues
in this country.
We have a journalism
stand-down in America.
It is a crisis.
Local TV is the main source.
But look at newspapers.
Newspapers in this
country have laid off
22,000 employees since 2009.
And every one of
them blames Google.
So just be aware that they all
are like, it's the internet.
But you know what
the problem was?
I've got good news for Google.
They were laying
them off before.
The fact of the
matter is the crisis
in newspaper journalism
started in 1950.
And we have had a steady decline
in the number of newspapers
in this country since the '50s.
And it was television much
more than the internet
that caused this crisis.
What the internet did
was take the ads away.
And this is a big deal,
because journalism
in America for a long
time was sustained by ads.
And everybody thought,
wow, what wonderful people.
All those big companies, the
car companies and the soda
companies, they just
give all this money
to newspapers and television
and radio to sustain journalism.
Well, it turns out, ironically
enough, they didn't.
They gave that
money because that
was the vehicle by which
they could get to you.
And so you got a newspaper.
You looked at it.
You didn't want to look at
the ad for the diapers but OK.
Sp then the next thing--
that's how they sold stuff.
TV the same way.
It doesn't happen
that way anymore.
That's not how it works.
I get my little phone here,
even when I'm on Twitter.
I was tweeting about
this incredible event.
And I've got little ads
coming on Twitter now.
The ads find me.
You know this.
I don't have to tell you this.
The ads follow people around.
The bottom line is
the ads don't go.
The ads don't go in
the newspaper anymore.
They don't go, by and
large, on TV anymore.
And so you have this deep
decline in journalism.
There is one set of
ads that do come in.
One set of ads do come in.
And that's the political ads.
And you know why?
You're just a screwed up bunch.
We've got a couple of
white-haired folks.
And I love you.
But by and large, you're
too young to vote.
In this country, the voting
class is old people, quite old.
That's why we can't
talk about anything
but social security
in this country,
because the fact of the
matter is our voting class
is overwhelmingly old.
And people think just about
presidential elections.
No.
You've got to go down that
food chain into local politics.
Bob talked about a 52% turnout.
Well, 52%, 53% of our
voting age population,
that's the mountaintop.
You go into state
and local elections,
you start creeping down to
numbers that are in, literally,
20%, 18%, 17%, 16%,
15%, 10% turnouts.
We just elected Cory
Booker to the US Senate
from New Jersey in a
20% turnout election.
That means if you met
five people on the street,
four of them didn't vote.
Well, roughly half of them
voted for Cory Booker.
That means he's going to the
United States Senate, the most
elite club in the
world with the support
of 10% of the electorate in the
state he's going to represent.
So we've got this
huge stand-down.
By and large, the people
who do vote are much older.
They still watch that
television evening news.
And so what do they get?
All the weather
they can possibly
use and then $6
billion worth of ads.
I don't think I have to explain
to people as smart as you
that what that leaves us with
is in the ideal propaganda
circumstance, right?
No information.
No information for
the voting class
that's of any
particular consequence
but a massive inflow of ads.
And what do those ads do?
What do they tell people to do?
Don't vote.
Imagine that
political ads are put
on TV to get people to vote.
That's not the point,
because remember,
we have a small voting class.
We have depressed our
voting class down.
And as we talk about in
the book, in many races,
as much as 90% to 95%
of the ads are negative.
And ask yourself this.
I'm going to take
this guy right here.
I'm going to say, you're
a sophisticated urban
intellectual, right?
You vote on a variety of
issues that concern you deeply.
I'm going to make
assumptions about you.
And I probably am wrong.
But I'm going to assume you
believe that people have
the right to make
choices at what
they do with their own body.
You believe that social
engineering by the right wing,
I don't want that.
I'm not going to vote
for some right wing
Rick Santorum for President
of the United States.
That's just not where
I'm going, because I've
got the cool glasses.
That's not who I'm going to be.
All right.
Cool.
So you see a negative
ad about the candidate
you decided to vote for.
You're going to vote for
this progressive candidate.
They're thinking liberally
on a whole bunch of things.
You see a negative ad
about that candidate.
And you're like,
well, that's it.
I'm voting for the
social conservative.
I'm going to vote
against everything
I believe in, because I saw a
negative ad about my candidate.
That's not what happens.
You see enough negative
ads about that candidate,
you say, a pox on
all their houses.
I'm just not going to vote.
And you stand down.
We talk a lot in this country
about voter suppression,
about voter ID laws,
and about other efforts
to make it hard to vote.
The number one voter
suppression in America
is negative ads, because
negative ads tell
tens of millions of Americans in
the primary place where they're
getting information about
politics still, don't vote.
Don't vote for the candidate
that you wanted to vote for,
because it turns
out that they are
the most evil
person in the world.
We actually did
this for the book.
We watched these ads.
California, right?
They don't campaign
in California anymore,
because you guys have
figured things out.
So bottom line is they go
to the handful of states
where they're like this
incredible creature,
the undecided voter.
Many of them live in the
Midwest where I'm from.
There are the kind of
people that can't decide.
I don't know.
Should I get up this morning?
And so the end result
is they pour these ads
into these states.
They are really awful.
They are unbelievably
troubling things.
Slasher films.
Nothing compared to this stuff.
And so people are
inundated with this.
And it tells them to
stand down from politics.
It's a really serious issue.
And this issue gets more
serious by the minute,
because in this country, we
have a bigger and bigger divide
between the handful of
engaged people, the people who
do-- they're like
Eric over here.
They're looking stuff up.
He's probably looking up the
turnout numbers right now.
And so we have a handful
of hyper-engaged people.
But then we have a growing
disconnect in this country.
And it's why it is
possible for people
to shut down the government.
It is why it is
possible for us to have
huge crises in Washington
about things that--
and you're a relatively
young guy here.
I know this is
going to shock you.
Old people like me,
when I was growing up,
I never knew there was such
a thing as a continuing
resolution.
I never knew there was such
a thing as a debt ceiling.
I didn't know about
government shutdown.
I've covered politics forever.
I didn't know that.
That never happened.
Now, it's all we talk about.
Why is it all we talk about?
Because when we
have depressed down
our political
participation, when
we have squeezed
information out of the game,
we create a game for
a handful of people,
a tiny number of
people, who participate
in gerrymandered
political circumstances.
Remember, now, in
America, it's the opposite
of what we think about.
Generally, voters
choose the candidates.
In America, the candidates,
the politicians,
choose their districts.
They choose their set of voters.
So if you're a certain
Democrat, here's
how we're going
to draw the lines.
The legislature
of California has
tried to break some of that.
But most of the country,
that's what they do.
So the end result is
across this country
when you have a
Congress-- and remember,
this Congress didn't
win, by the way.
This is an important
thing to understand.
Last year, 1.7
million more people
voted for Democrats for the
House of Representatives
than voted for Republicans.
But because of the
gerrymandering,
because of structural flaws
in how we do our elections,
the Republicans have
control of the House,
not because more people
wanted them to, but because
of the structures of
how we do our politics.
The end result is that those
people who are there, everybody
said, well, why don't the
Republicans stand down?
Why don't they realize?
This is incredibly unpopular.
The Gallup Poll just showed
that the Republican Party
has a lower approval
rating today
that at any time since
Gallup started polling
on the approval
of major parties.
It's unbelievable.
Ted Cruz is still saying,
I didn't do anything wrong.
And why?
Because they don't fear
November elections.
They don't fear
the mass turnout.
They've drawn the districts.
They've structured the money.
They've structured the politics.
So the only problem they've
got is their primary.
They don't want to be
challenged by somebody
who is more extreme
than they are.
And so as a result, you
end up with a situation
where your entire politics,
the governance of the nation,
is defined by people
who are afraid of people
who are crazier than they are.
That, I want to tell you,
is not a healthy democracy.
Amazingly enough, this is not
what Jefferson and Madison
imagined back in 1787.
And so as we approach
all these issues,
we realize we're not at
the full crisis point yet.
We are moving rapidly toward
it, because this next election
cycle, we had $10 billion.
And by the way, here's a little
something for Google to do.
When we started the research
on this-- one of you
could do this, because I
have such reverence for you.
One of you could do this.
Do know that there's no
agency in America that
charts all the
money that's spent?
It's independent.
The Federal Election Commission
doesn't begin to do it.
Independent groupings do it
at the federal or state level.
Nobody does it nationwide
what all is spent.
We did it for our book.
It was incredibly hard.
It took the better
part of the year.
We went state by state,
community by community.
What we saw was huge amounts of
money flooded into local races,
where you get the most power,
where you decide on zoning,
where you decide on delivery of
services and things like that.
A San Jose race where they
spent half million dollars
for a city council seat.
California referendums.
Last year in
California, $550 million
was spent on referendums in
California, these initiatives,
particularly that
tell you that you
don't want to know whether your
food is genetically modified.
And so the end result
of this is that we
come into this situation in a
very troubling point, the point
where it could get a lot worse.
And what we propose is to think
like you folks think I hope.
I hope I'm not making too
much of an assumption.
And that is you don't
look at a problem
from the standpoint of
what everybody's done up
to this point to
solve the problem.
You don't narrow your options.
You say, how do
we fix the crisis?
What we need to do in America
is do massive interventions
in how we communicate.
We have to figure out
how to democratize
the flow of information,
so that working
class people, the mom who
works at a Wendy's window
and then has to go
home and put three kids
to sleep and then has
to go out that night
and work at the
McDonald's window,
how she gets enough
information to be
a participant in
our democratic life,
how it is not cut
off from her and all
she sees is negative ads.
So we have to think
a lot about that.
But we also have to
think a lot about how
to renew our democracy.
And this is big deal stuff.
We have to amend
our constitution.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I know when somebody says,
amend the Constitution, you say,
that's impossible.
It's never been done.
The Constitution was written
in stone, handed down
on tablets to Michele Bachmann.
And it's never been altered,
well, except for 27 times.
27 times we've amended
our Constitution.
The founders amended it
10 times in the first four
years of the Republic.
And then about a decade later,
when the vice president shot
the secretary of
the treasury, they
decided to amend
it again to pick
a different way of
getting vice presidents.
And so we've amended
the Constitution
throughout our
history as a country.
We have amended it most often
to make our democracy work.
Everybody loves the New Deal.
We talk about Roosevelt.
One of the lost realities
of the New Deal era
was at the start of
the New Deal era,
they did two amendments
to the Constitution
that no one ever talks about.
Eric can look them up.
And the one amendment said that
when a president is elected,
instead of being sworn
in in the spring,
he's sworn in in January.
That moved the process down.
Remember we talked, some of
the older folks will remember,
the story of Roosevelt's
first 100 days.
We made possible the
meaning of a first 100 days
by collapsing in the
time between the election
and when he became president.
That was huge.
The other thing we did was say
that the Congress of the United
States met immediately
in January, rather than
deep into the next year.
Previously, before that,
the way the Constitution
was structured,
Congress was elected.
The people who were
elected did not
come in to sit until
well into the next year.
As a result, those who
had been defeated actually
governed for the better part
of a year after the election.
We changed these things to
make our democracy work.
And we did a lot
of other changes.
We gave women the right to vote.
After the Civil War, we
gave African American men
the right to vote.
We gave Native Americans
In 1962, in the lifetime of
some people in this room,
we struck down the
wealth barrier to voting
in this country.
We banned the poll tax
constitutionally in 1962.
1970 we said that people
who are 18 to 21 years old,
who go off and fight
in wars, get drafted
to die in foreign
lands, ought to be
able to vote in the elections
that would determine
whether we fight those wars.
We have amended our Constitution
again and again and again
in this country to repair the
problems of our democracy.
And the great gap today is that
because our media is so bad,
because it doesn't
cover politics,
our media covers Washington.
It covers dysfunction
in Washington.
Most people don't
know that we are
in another
constitutional moment.
16 American states have
formally petitioned the Congress
of the United States to overturn
the Citizens United ruling
and to say corporations
are not people.
Money is not speech.
And we the citizens
of the United States
have a right to form elections
in which the vote matters more
than the dollar.
16 American states
have already done this.
500 communities across the
country have done this.
Los Angeles did it
earlier this year.
San Francisco has
already done it.
I wouldn't be surprised if
Mountain View has done it.
But the fact of the
matter is there's
this huge cry across this
country to make the change.
And the interesting
thing is it's not just
Democrats and liberals.
The fact of the matter
is everybody gets this.
Last year, they put a
referendums on the ballot
in Montana and in Colorado.
Colorado was an Obama state.
Montana was a Romney state.
They had a referendum on a
Constitutional amendment.
Each state voted roughly
73% in favor of doing it.
Republican members
of legislatures
across this country have
worked with Democrats
to encourage this.
Recently we got the
first Republican
in Congress, Walter Jones, a
deep passionate conservative
from the Carolinas,
to sign on and say,
we need this
constitutional amendment.
Because if we don't
make democracy changes
to our Constitution, as hard
as it is with all the barriers
that are out there, we cannot
begin to structure the money
out, and to structure
the people in.
So that's the bottom line.
I come and ask you think
of yourselves as founders.
Think of yourselves
as people who
want to shape an actual
democracy in this country.
And then because of
your special genius,
think of yourselves
as people who
can help to form a communication
system in this country that
makes sure everybody
can vote and everybody
can cast an informed vote.
Big deal stuff.
We're glad to be with you today.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Mic
here for questions.
AUDIENCE: Madison native, former
writer for the "Simpson Street
Free Press."
JOHN NICHOLS: No way.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
JOHN NICHOLS: All
right, brother.
How old are you?
AUDIENCE: I'm 28.
JOHN NICHOLS: So you probably
were wandering around the "Cap
Times" newsroom
sometimes trying to--
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
Evjue Foundation.
JOHN NICHOLS: Evjue.
AUDIENCE: Evjue, sorry.
I actually first saw you
speak at the Fighting
Bob Fest in Baraboo
12 years ago.
JOHN NICHOLS: The rest
of you can leave now.
AUDIENCE: This is Wisconsin
progressive trivia for you.
My question centers
more around media.
So with Bezos purchasing the
"Washington Post" and it's
been an onset Pierre
Omidyar is launching
this huge $250 million
project in conjunction
with some former
"Guardian" reporters--
JOHN NICHOLS: With
Glenn Greenwald
who did the NSA stuff,
perhaps with Jeremy Scahill,
my colleague from "The
Nation" and some other folks.
AUDIENCE: So a lot of what you
guys just spoke about centers
around what has
happened to media,
how newsrooms have been gutted.
Folks that rely on
their 5 o'clock news
aren't getting the news that
we would like them to get.
How do you see media changing?
You guys have an inside view.
And I'm really
curious to see what
do the next 5 to 20
years of media look like?
And what do you think,
especially a long-term tech
vision, can bring
to an industry that
has been so depleted
by market forces?
JOHN NICHOLS: I will
let Bob do this one.
But before I do, you've just
asked, literally, the top media
scholar in the world to do like
a minute on the future media.
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY:
Real quickly.
John talked about this.
The reason why Jeff Bezos was
able to buy "The Washington
Post" for $250 million when Hedy
wanted to buy it 10 years ago,
it would have cost
him $6 billion,
is that the market
has determined
that commercial journalism
is no longer profitable.
And the reason for that is what
John started talking about.
Advertising online no longer
has to support content.
It's been detached from content.
And journalism for
the last 100 years
received between 50% and 100% of
its revenues from advertising.
Well, online you place
your ads through networks.
The website gets far less
percentage of the revenue
than it used to.
In 2003, a newspaper website
got 100% of its ad revenue
from its advertising.
By 2010, it was down to 20%.
Today it's under 10%.
And it's approaching
0% like a parabola.
So there's not a
commercial market left,
which is why Bezos got
it for such little money.
In our view, to sum
up really quickly,
this is a fundamental political
issue for this country.
How are we going to have the
resources to have competing
independent newsrooms covering
our communities drawing us
into public life?
And it's a political issue,
because the market has voted.
And the solution,
in our view, is
by looking at how other
democracies address it,
in Europe and East
Asia, and also
how the United States addressed
it the 100 years before we
had advertising provide
the lion's share of support
of journalism, when we had
the greatest free press
system in the world.
And what we had then were
massive postal and printing
subsidies which spawned this
incredible press system.
And what we find
in other countries
is enlightened policies in
places like Germany, Denmark,
Norway, and Sweden that spawn
an independent, uncensored free
press and also supports diverse
newspapers in communities too.
I'm not saying we should
adopt their policies.
But we have to start
having that discussion,
because the market
will not generate
independent journalism.
That has been voted by the
marketplace emphatically.
JOHN NICHOLS: And let
me just to come off
that for one other thing.
And I'm going to go whack job
libertarian on you here, OK?
Because in our book,
we talk about a lot
of different fixes for media.
And I do recommend the book.
It makes a fun holiday gift.
But to cut to the chase, one
of the best ideas we've seen
came from an economist
named Dean Baker.
And he said, look, the
underpinning of democracy
is information.
An informed vote
is what matters.
It's not just a vote to make
you just rubber stamping stuff.
That's not the point.
You have to have information.
It's so important that we ought
to give every American $100
credit or tax write-off
that they can direct
to any independent
not-for-profit media
at the local, state,
or national level.
And they can make the choices.
They can sustain media.
Other countries actually
experiment with this, Sweden
and others, where they
look at some of these tax
credits, other models
where you can support media
that you regard well.
At in fact, the United
States experiments with it
all the time.
We allow billionaires
and stock speculators
to write off their subscription
to the "Wall Street Journal,"
because it's considered
vital information
for your economic life.
You can write it right off.
Academics can write
off the journals
that they read for
their academic work.
Citizens can't write off
their support for media.
We think an idea
like that, which
we build a left-right
coalition, we would hope,
would be a good way to start.
And then you ask us.
We actually were thrilled
to come to Google,
because we want you
people genuinely
to start to think
about how to do this.
But we will tell you there
is a political part to this.
You have to recognize that.
And one of the best ways, one
of the best models for it,
is to say, why don't you
create great ideas for how
to do all this and let us create
a model where citizens can then
sustain, in a very open free
way, the journalism they like?
You're sitting, by
the way, down the row
from Craig Aaron, who is the
president and CEO of Free
Press, the group
that we co-founded.
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY: He's
working on these issues.
JOHN NICHOLS: And Free Press
works on all these issues
all the time.
And so I would recommend
check out their website.
Throw out the things
you don't like.
Don't buy into the
things you don't like.
But explore these ideas,
because we genuinely
need a lot of smart people
in the mix of figuring out
how we create a communication
system that sustains democracy.
AUDIENCE: So many
fascinating issues.
We could talk for hours
about all of them, I'm sure.
The one I wanted to
ask you about though
was the 28th Amendment
that you're proposing.
I totally share your values
and objectives there.
Yet I do remain a little bit
skeptical about the limitation
on using money.
This is the way that people
speak in this country
oftentimes.
And there were
issues where I agree
with the funding, a
billionaire coming in,
whether it's Larry or
Sergei funding something
on a carbon tax.
So I'm wondering why
not have a thing where
you do the first part
of it, where you say,
only entities that can vote in
this election can contribute.
Any person who can vote
can contribute unlimitedly
with disclosure.
And I know the Supreme
Court is trying
to fight some of the
disclosure parts of this.
What would be the
problem with that?
It seems to me that that
preserves free speech, as well
as freedom of association,
that I think are very vital.
And footnote, our values
are winning actually.
If you read things
like "Victory Lab,"
we can spend the money better.
So why would we want
from a utilitarian point
of view unilaterally disarm?
JOHN NICHOLS: Let me take
a quick piece of that
and let Bob take it.
Eric, I love you.
You're the man.
You were looking up
the Powell memo there.
Come on.
And you're doing exactly
what we want you to do.
When we come out, we don't
specify a specific amendment.
We actually think there
are several amendments that
ought to be done.
We think a Supreme
Court that tells you
that money should flow
easily into politics,
but it should be hard to vote
is wrong on several counts.
So we would like to not
only do an amendment
as regards to the
money, we would also
like to do an
amendment that says,
everybody has a right
to vote and a right
to have that vote counted.
But what you've just done
is exactly what we want.
You are talking about how you
would sculpt that amendment.
And the fact of the
matter is every amendment
to the Constitution of
any consequence has not
come about wholly
formed at the beginning.
It ends up with people starting
to think about the idea,
thinking about what
they want to render
and what they want to defend,
and making something real.
And so I don't disregard
a lot of what you say.
Although Bob may toss
you off completely.
But what I will tell you
is that kind of engagement
is where we have to be.
Our problem in America is we're
not having those discussions.
We're not talking about
how to structurally make
this thing work.
And a final thing
I'll tell you about
constitutional amendments.
This is a big deal.
When you talk about a
constitutional amendment,
you don't always have to
get it to fix the problem.
This is the interesting thing.
When we had the Equal
Rights Amendment,
the women in the
room will be aware
that it's not been enacted.
We don't have an Equal Rights
Amendment to our Constitution.
But the multi-year fight to
get an Equal Rights Amendment
helped to open the
door for Title IX,
for workplace protections for
women, for Lilly Ledbetter Act,
and a host of other
breakthroughs.
On the right and the left,
a constitutional amendment
strategy does not have
to be completed in order
to begin to address the
crisis along the way.
But if you don't shoot big,
if you don't go for something
to say, this is such
a serious issue,
we have to talk
about it in this way,
you don't possibly get to
the incremental changes
along the way.
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY:
Well, I think
the problem with
unlimited spending
is what I talked about already.
I won't repeat it.
There's a difference
between a small spending
and a large spending.
And the other problem is that
it also reinforces the idea
that politics is
for billionaires
and really wealthy people.
And we get to be spectators.
If you have money, you can
buy in and be a player.
If you don't, you just
hope that your team wins.
You root for the billionaire
you most agree with.
And I don't think
that's a healthy thing.
I think that we look at
how other democracies that
are much more successful by
all the criteria, whoever
makes them, wealthy people have
a lot of influence in society.
They don't need
to buy elections.
They can start groups.
They can do education campaigns.
There's lots of ways they
can influence politics
if that's their goal.
The election process should
be kept, as much as possible,
a level playing field.
That really is
mandatory for democracy
to be credible and succeed.
And that's what we've
lost in this country.
Now, your other point though
I completely agree with.
The premise of our book
is that this is not
a reactionary country.
This is not a dumb country.
This is not a
country that buys in.
The great tension here is
when we go around to talks,
this is the smallest room
we've played in 40 talks.
People get it.
They're concerned.
This is a progressive country.
Young people, in
particular, are really
queued in that we've got to
change this governing system.
It's not working.
And that's why
we're so optimistic.
And I think the
key point I would
close with as we're getting
near the witching hour
is that it's striking that
in the last five years
this great movement has been
on two fronts politically.
One is to unleash the
power of unlimited money
by the wealthiest
institutions and individuals.
On the other hand, the
Supreme Court has worked hard
and state governments
have worked hard
to make it harder and harder for
poor people and people of color
to vote, literally reenacting
Jim Crow statutes now
in five Southern states.
Something that is obscene.
It would've been
illegal two years ago.
The reason why they're doing
that, making it easy for money
to flood elections, making
it harder for poor people
to get to the
polls, is they know
they can't win a fair election.
That system is
really that fragile.
We just need to organize.
And we will win.
We need to recognize that we
have the numbers on our side.
We have the wind at our sails.
They're a dying system.
That's what they're doing
this monkey in Congress, where
they're trying to
stall the government.
Any of the issues they're
trying to push through
would never pass a fair test.
So they've got to close the
government down, put a gun
at the head, and say, you
give us our way or we shoot,
because the know if they
have to put it to a vote,
they would lose.
They can only do
it by blackmail.
AUDIENCE: So given the amount
of money that goes into
or the fact that news
sources are so often funded
by large groups, large
individuals, people
with a lot of money
and whatnot, do
you have any recommendations
for either news sources or ways
to determine that the news
sources you're listening to
aren't simply
giving you the news
that someone with a lot of power
and/or money wants you to know?
JOHN NICHOLS: Well, let me
begin by saying, of course,
you could just Google a
good news source, right?
I'm teasing.
AUDIENCE: So the
problem is, sure, you
can find news sources.
But you don't know--
JOHN NICHOLS: That's
what I'm saying.
But that's what
people actually do.
Poor people across America,
they're like, well,
I've got to find something.
And unfortunately
what they end up with
isn't always as
genius as Google is.
They don't always end up
with the perfect news source.
And so the answer
to the question
is diversity and
encountering voices.
We get this question
everywhere we go.
And the first thing I
always tell people is,
read something that you
really disagree with a lot.
I'm serious.
I write for "The
Nation" magazine.
Our equivalent is arguably
"National Review,"
the very conservative magazine.
I read "National
Review" all the time.
It's pretty well written.
I think they've become a little
bit more scared of their base.
But the bottom line is I still
read them on a regular basis.
And I find it very important.
I read a lot of
conservative publications,
because I think that
helps to inform me.
I also read international
publications,
because I want to read about
America from the perspective
that other people see it.
So I go to "The Guardian"
a lot in Britain.
I think they're
very, very useful.
I go to a lot of the
German publications, which
have great English language
translation, because I'm not
the best German speaker.
And the bottom line
is that when you
start to read about how
other people see you,
it starts to give you
a lot of perspective.
I happen to like "Deutsche
Welle." "Der Spiegel's," I
think, coverage of the US
is actually quite good.
And so go for all that.
But this is the conundrum.
So I hope that
helps a little bit.
But the question you ask
gets to the conundrum
of what we're talking
about, because all
across America-- I don't
care who we're with.
I don't care if we're in a
church basement or union hall
or in Google or
wherever we're at,
people say, how do I figure
out what I can trust?
Well, the answer
to that question
is, you can't trust anybody.
What you can trust
is a diverse system
that gives you a lot of
different perspectives.
And then you search
through that.
You find things
that, ultimately,
touch you that mean
something to you.
And then you use all of that.
But increasingly in
America, people are getting
a one-size-fits-all bit of
news that is more likely to be
defined by a negative campaign
ad than by a detailed smart bit
of coverage.
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY:
Just to add to that.
The sort of partisanization
this of news in America,
especially cable
news, is directly
a function of the
lack of journalism,
because this is actually Rupert
Murdoch's brilliant business
move what he did with Fox News.
It wasn't that he said,
let's have a channel
that will simply
give the Republican
Party talking
points every night.
So if you want to know
what they're thinking,
you can go to this channel.
Instead, he said, if I don't
have any journalists, if I
don't cover anything, if I
don't have a news room, what can
I do to make people
come to my channel?
Well, you give them opinions.
You give them ideologies.
So he hired
charismatic presenters
to present the talking points.
And it's very inexpensive to do.
John does cable
news all the time.
There are no reporters or
people covering anything there.
You've got producers
and bookers.
But they don't do
any journalism.
They just give
you talking points
on the issues of the day.
And this reinforces
the sense that people
are going into their
self-defined little cubby
holes.
They're not seeing what
the rest of the world
sees, because I would
read "National Review."
I subscribe to "The Economist"
and "Financial Times."
They are core reading for me.
But I go to Fox News.
And after three
minutes, I'm bored.
I know the Republican
Party talking points.
They aren't educating me
on any interesting ideas.
And I suspect a conservative
would go to MSNBC and feel
the same way, not
to pick on MSNBC.
JOHN NICHOLS: When you and
I'm on, it's quite good.
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY: When
John's on, it's different.
But if we had
substantive reporting,
I think that issue about people
being in their cubby holes
would disappear,
because I remember
this wasn't an issue 30
or 40 years ago, when
we had much more
substantial reporting
across the political spectrum.
And it was routine
that people on the left
would read conservative
and conservative left.
It wasn't considered weird.
Today, it's sort of
weird if you watch
Fox News for any length of
time for any of my friends,
you think, what are
you badgering yourself
with this idiocy
for, to be blunt.
JOHN NICHOLS: To
popcorn off this,
I'll give you one final point.
I was once traveling
from Jerusalem
to Bethlehem on a
Palestinian bus.
This kid is sitting
next to me, and he
had three newspapers
on his lap--
or six newspapers-- three Hebrew
language papers, three Arabic
language papers.
And he's 15, 16 years old.
I said, what's up
with that, man?
Are you a paper boy?
And he said, no, no.
I try to read them
all every day,
because I'm trying to
figure out this whole thing.
I mean we've got this
thing with the Jews
and the Palestinians
and the Christians.
And I want to get it right.
Well, I love that kid, right?
That's what we're
supposed to do.
And actually, what you folks
do, when you Google something
and you get a lot
of articles up,
that's a very good
model of that.
But the bottom line
is, again, I want
to emphasize the people who
are doing that, that kid was
a self-selected-- he's probably
in the Palestinian parliament
today or whatever or maybe
the Israeli parliament.
But the bottom line
is that most Americans
are rushing through their
lives very, very fast.
It's faster than ever.
And they're getting little
snippets of information.
And unfortunately, the
constant information
they get on politics
repeated again and again
is the negative ad 100
times, 1,000 times.
In some media
markets, you can see
ads for a particular candidate
as much as 2,000 or 3,000 times
before an election.
You're going to remember that.
You're not going to remember
a little quick newscast.
AUDIENCE: I really enjoyed your
previous book, "Our Media."
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY: Oh.
That's an oldy.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question about this claim
that the political advertising
is reducing participation
because it also draws out
the fringes, at least that's
what they say in the media.
But the question I have
is about the hypothesis
that really previously
we had either newspapers
or we had three big networks.
And everyone got
all of their news
from the national
and then the local,
during the '70s
when I was a kid.
And now, it's fractured into all
of these specialized networks
that echo your preferences.
So before people were
educated because they
had no other outlets
and so they were stuck
with a more broad presentation
of the issues of the day,
and now they don't
have that, so there
are things like "Democracy
Now" that does great reporting
but has a very small readership,
I guess, or audience.
So it seems like you have
to get the news, good news,
adjacent to how people are
living their busy lives.
So that seems like
a bigger problem,
even though we should
fix campaign finance.
JOHN NICHOLS: Believe
me, we wrote this book
to not make that division.
To say, we've got
to fix our politics.
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY: Media
right in the middle of it.
JOHN NICHOLS: But
one of the things I
do, and I didn't do it here
because I didn't get here
in time.
I often go when
I come to a town,
and I go to an antique store.
They have stacks of the
old papers from the town.
And I get the local daily
paper from 50 years ago.
And I just hold it
up to the people.
And we would go
through the front page.
We go through a
couple pages of it.
People's jaws drop, because
local daily newspapers
50 years ago, the range
of things they covered
would blow your mind.
They had three or four
pages of international news.
Even in the local paper
in Palo Alto or San Jose,
they had news from states
around the country.
I was in Duluth,
Minnesota, once.
And I picked up a paper.
It had a Ralph Nader press
conference from 50 years
ago or roughly 50 years ago.
It had civil rights stuff.
It had labor stuff,
all this stuff.
Well, we have squeezed
it down to such an extent
that it isn't just
that they had three
networks and their local
paper in those days.
The institutions actually gave
them a lot of information.
It was considered the
way that you did it.
And people also got magazines.
Do you know what I mean?
They had many sources.
Today, we have much more
access to information.
But in the cacophony, we
don't have that easy access
where you live and
in your community,
because that local
paper that I pick up,
in addition to all that global
stuff and all that stuff
from around the country,
also had a reporter who
was tasked every day to
go cover the school board,
a reporter tasked every day
to go cover the city council.
When you read
through that paper,
you knew what was happening
in your community.
And today, it is
very hard, if you
live in a suburb
around San Francisco,
to know what's happening
in your community,
unless some desperate citizen
blogger is out there doing
the game.
But the only problem with
that is the desperate citizen
blogger might not actually be
trying to give the full story.
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY: The
crucial point here again,
not to be Johnny One
Note, is that we've
lost resources to journalism.
And I think that resources to
journalism, people get paid.
They're responsible for a beat.
There are competing
journalists covering it.
So if someone misses it,
someone else will get it.
So there's that
spur of competition.
We've lost that.
And I've made a career of
being critical of the type
of journalism we came out of,
as you know from our media
and not theirs.
And the problem is
that I think we've
had a tendency to look at
old media versus new media.
And there's a split there, when
that's an irrelevant concern.
They are really
these concerns that
are using different
technologies at this point.
And the great crisis is
that on the digital realm
with advertising no longer
supporting journalism,
there aren't the
resources for journalism.
And it's worse online
than it is in old media.
That's the last
place there are still
funds going to pay journalists.
If we lose online journalists,
the reporting, like John
does for "The Nation," he gets
paid from a print publication.
But he's all over the web.
I mean every day he's
posting articles to the web.
If "The Nation" can't
afford to pay him anymore
because they can't
stay in business,
then John is not writing
on the web anymore.
That's the irony of our times
is old media is supporting much
of the original
content we consider
what we get we go
online to see news.
Because you're here
at Google, and I
know this is a great concern
of yours, that there's content
online that you can
then deliver to people
and make it useful to people.
I think this issue of how we're
going to somehow get resources
to independent competing
journalists who are getting
paid to do work and cover
elections and cover communities
is just foundational.
Just keep that in your minds.
It's certainly the
issue we work on.
JOHN NICHOLS: And one
last element there,
as long as Eric is here,
because Eric Googles stuff.
Just Google the Pew
study on Baltimore.
Just Google those words--
Pew study on Baltimore.
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY: From 2009.
JOHN NICHOLS: From 2009 or '10.
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY:
Well, it came out in '10.
But it was based in '09.
JOHN NICHOLS: And
incredible study
that just showed how people get
their information, old media,
new media, the interplay of it.
I won't go into
detail beyond that it.
It lays it all out.
We've also written
some essays on it.
But if you Google Pew
study journalism Baltimore,
most of the stuff
you talked about,
it's laid bare in
some incredible ways.
ROBERT W. MCCHESNEY: Well,
thank you all very much.
JOHN NICHOLS: Thank you.
Wow.
We loved you.
Thank you so much
for having us on.
That was very nice of you.
[APPLAUSE]